foreign
it's as simple as that I read a blog
post a little while ago saying that you
can keep your chicken's water from
freezing by putting a salt water
solution in a 20 ounce bottle I'll link
to the article down below I don't know
if it's going to work but let's try it
today and see what happens I've been
waiting for it to get cold out again
um we're 15 degrees today
it's a pretty simple process it just
calls for a quarter of a cup
salt
I'm using rock salt and it says fill it
up the rest of the way with water I'm
just using a little warm water to help
melt the salt
[Music]
pump load up
all right it's as simple as that I hope
we've been using the salt water solution
for three days now today's the coldest
morning it's 9 degrees Fahrenheit out
let's go check and see if the chicken's
water froze overnight come on Pluto
let's go check on the chickens come on
foreign
noisy roaster sounds about right here at
London Acres that guy crows all day all
night long sometimes we'll hear them at
like two three in the clock in the
morning no ice build up there
a little bit here on the sides you can
feel it I'm gonna call that a success
it's not below zero out but it's nine
degrees out and the water didn't freeze
overnight
so I'm happy with that ends up freezing
when it gets below zero that's fine I
can deal with that every once in a while
we've had good success so far with this
I hope you do too leave it in the
comments down below what you think share
the video it really helps we'll see you
right back here next time at London
Acres a guide to Modern homesteading
self-sufficiency and freedom
thank you
foreign